what's going on there citizens of the reject
Nation we saw episode 2 of The Last of Us now
it is time to watch from our friend Paul over
at heavy spoilers go check out his channel
because he is killing it he's become The Last
of Us Channel his breakdown in Easter eggs for
The Last of Us episode dos join with me is the
man who I'm covering the last of us with Andrew
Gordon agor 7-Eleven who you can tell has been
hit with a cordyceps infection with his red eye
today I I am infected you should stay away from
me Greg no no no I got a special kind of blood
ladies and Gentlemen please go ahead leave a
like that'd be very much appreciated also uh
you can go check out our reaction for the
second episode The Last of Us that is up
here on this channel John and Tara the non-gamer
reaction that'll be up Manana that is tomorrow
in Spanish in honor of Gabriel Luna and Pedro
Pascal now uh let's move on to this reaction
welcome to the heavy spoiler show I'm your host
Paul AKA not your average Joel in this video
we're breaking down The Last of Us episode too
the series has had two really good episodes back
to back and is a big fan of the game I've loved
watching these first two entries They do change
some things up though and throughout the video
we're going to be going over the Easter eggs
game differences and also giving our thoughts
on the series so far huge thank you to everyone
who watched our video last week I've said that
to you so many times Easter eggs until the end
so that people who haven't played the game can
enjoy the twists and turns that come up in the
show I'll give you a heads up before we hit that
and we start the episode off in Jakarta all the
way back in 2003. if you cast your mind back
to last week then you may remember that they
did an announcement over the radio that talked
about the city and how summing strangers going
on there yes here we see it playing out with
the outbreak of the infection being studied by
a doctor this wasn't in the game and I like how
the series is slowly filling in the backstory of
the virus yes both the beginning of the last
episode and this one had completely new bits
in them and it's possible that we might even get a
story slotted in at the opening of each entry that
gives us way more details on the infection than
what we ever got in the game now in the game if
I'm not a mistake we don't really know the full
extent of how this virus came to be right so it
seems like Neil drupin in a conjunction with
Craig I want to say Mason is working together
to actually deliver for us what the backstory
of the virus truly is and how it all came to be
yeah from what I remember and you guys can correct
me if I'm wrong I think there was some newspaper
clippings in the video game that said like it
originated out of South America in Mexico or
something like that and so there wasn't too much
context there but we kind of talked about this too
that I love you know in the first two episodes
how they have these prologues here that kind of
just again explain this and they're done really
methodically and really interesting and again
just give a really good explanation the backstory
to how the cordyceps brain infection just started
and originated so I love what they're doing these
first two episodes just filling in the gaps of how
it all started now when the title cosplay shown we
can see this is taking place on September 24 2003
dating it two days before the outbreak of course
shows how fast the virus spread and in the game we
learn it was through products containing flower
and yeast which we'll talk more about in just
a bit huge it out to Dynamic Smurf on our last
video for pointing out that 2003 was potentially
chosen because it was one of the hottest years in
records [__] Heat Wave happening that killed 20
000 people the subtitles will enjoy this part
of the show also highly resemble the captions
from the game amazing is more in The Last of
Us world that's a good cast we shot off with
a sunny seemingly normal day in Indonesia which is
when the military arrive and summon the scientists
to a lab though the world is stabilized The Last
of Us storylines filled with different militant
factions throughout that all try to seize power
to impose their rule fedrow were of course a big
part of these and I love how in the backdrop
there's always the idea of Us Versus Them us
or them this is Zachary Naboo who's pretty
fearful that she's been taken in she suspects
they think she's committed crime but they want it
because she's a professor in mycology mycology is
the study of fungi and she's the top scientist
after having graduated from the University of
Indonesia IBU is escorted Pastor reception desk
and this actually leaked online when the show
was in production she walks past several vaccine
advertisements as well and these are all ripping
on the week into a poster he once more get at ham
at home that is no cure and this is why Ellie is
such a Paramount person in the story Nobu Ratner
then examines the specimen and he's taken to one
of the infected that that we can't show can't
show it trust bloody HBO to have a fully nude
woman they can't bloody help themselves the woman
has a bullet hole in her head and she clearly only
stopped once she was shot around her foot we see
a bite mark and upon being opened up this spreads
out like the ones from Mrs Adler's mouth last
week still so gross a really creepy Dimension
to the entire thing now I didn't want to bring up
the clickers last week as it could have spoiled
some stuff for people who didn't want to know
but we finally get to meet some in this episode
out they don't disappoint either and through their
biology we can see how the cordyceps work they
basically infect a person and then they spread
through their body slowly replacing themselves
with fungi so they very much become almost like
a living mushroom I mean it's awesome from Mario
he ain't got [__] on these and the fungus
eventually completely devours their brain and
the upper part of their head this makes them blind
and it's why the clickers are called that because
they use echolocation in order to see their
surroundings right in the hotel gel brings up
how the majority of the infected die quite quickly
but those that are sustained go on living for
decades this is very much the case in the clickers
with them being infected that have been around for
decades and thus the fungus have managed to take
over most of their body and transform them into
these monsters while the the show match to do
two things make it harder to kill the clickers
also somehow you survive longer when fighting the
clickers in the show Because unless you got like
a ship ready to go you will die right away yeah
it's such a pain in the ass okay for sure and you
made you made a great point when you're player
you're in control and then when you're watching
these characters there's such more tension again
they just had did a great job of capturing like
wow the clickers are so much tougher to kill and
like you really feel a sense of danger for our
main characters I love the look of the clickers
on the show too and the body movements they just
really nailed it in that in episode two I love
the way that the cool decepts are located in the
mouth yeah and it hits at them slowly taking over
the inside but we can't tell until the infection
is further down the line maybe Rana has a cup of
tea and she learns that things started a flowering
grain Factory now the reason why I think chicato
was chosen is because it actually has the biggest
flower Mill in the entire world the bagasari flour
mill ranks as the largest on the planet in terms
of size and scale and research damn that is some
real research in here anyway she refers to it as
being the perfect substrate and in biology this
is a term used to describe the surface in which
fungus lives cheers Google enzymes here that cause
chemical processes and this may be how the virus
mutated to infect humans now when it comes to how
the fungus spread the game engine is how it got
in the food and a flower and yeast Factory would
be the perfect place for this to happen when we
look back at episode 1 there was actually a lot
of food that will contain this ingredient that
the characters in the show actually managed to
avoid we had moments where the younger Mrs Adler
made some cookies and flowers because they had
raisins in them I was thinking we'd make some
cookies chocolate chip raisin uh you don't need
Mr Radler could also be seen feeding the elderly
Mrs Adler and this could be where the infection
started out at that is crazy sad but I'm on Atkins
what now which in case you don't know is a low
carb diet meaning that things that have a lot
of flour and yeast in are completely avoided you
know I realized if Joel were to ever turn if you
were to ever feed on human flesh he would still
technically probably be on the Atkins diet still
probably but yeah no that was clever I like
that too because we saw in that first episode
he forgot the cake they avoided she avoided
the cookies Tommy didn't have the pancakes
so and all things had a flower in it by the way I
can't stop seeing Thandie Newton anymore now that
we know that that's her daughter I believe the
correct did I say it wrong person pronunciation
is tandy oh okay what I just say Mission
Impossible 2 chick how's that is that good that
work for you yes okay everyone's best everyone's
favorite Mission Impossible film thank you John
Wu now in the morning Tommy was good that they
weren't having pancakes because Joel and Sarah
had bacon and eggs again they're avoiding flower
products and they also didn't even have a birthday
cake either so the entire day was them just
dodging bullets there is a lot of emphasis on the
food no I don't know if Joe would have completely
sorry I don't know if Joel would have completely
skipped I'm sorry I don't know if Joe would have
completely skipped out on bread when food was
spare but I at least they kept that consistent
he says the woman bit three other co-workers and
that they were all executed but that they don't
know who bit him and thus the virus is still out
there 14 other workers are missing as well and
there's not really any way to put a lid on this
even if they lock down the country the cordyceps
have mutated now and it's only so long before
someone stumbles into them when they're out in
the wild oh she says that the whole city has to be
destroyed and we see how this strategy was adopted
worldwide do the craters later on in the game I
was just assumed they were collapsed part of the
streets due to lack of Maintenance but you should
never assume because it makes a uh anyway there's
no hope and she wants to spend the remaining hours
that she has left with her family it's a really
Bleak way to intro the episode and we know that
the following 20 years will likely hell on Earth
due to how far the virus spread it turned the
infected against everyone around them and even her
going back to her family is something that you'll
likely not experience again now Ellie very much
represents the Hub work here and this is shown
symbolically with a sleeping under a literal
ray of light that shines down on her gel and
Tess sit in the dark almost like it's a painting
of Jesus or something a butterfly flies over here
an imagery of these have appeared throughout
the series so far oh interest lies actually
carry their own meaning and typically they're used
to represent rebirth transformation and a change
in a positive direction and she has the potential
to cure Humanity I love that touch the way things
were where everyone was nice in the YouTube
comments section when you use what all nice
anyway she's again wearing the same t-shirt that
she had on last week and if you missed that then
we thought it was put on together to Young Nathan
Drake in Uncharted 3. not pulling that out of thin
air yeah it has a reason and naughty dog made both
Uncharted and also The Last of Us games nothing
but net now they're still pretty stuff to go over
whether she's immune or not and Ellie ends up
having to go to the toilet she's tossed a magazine
and in the game she ended up coming across some
beauty posters which she was completely stunned
by that girl is so skinny oh I never hit that part
I thought you had plenty of food in your time
well we did some just chose not to eat it this
happened just before the hotel which we ended up
visiting in the game though it appeared way later
on I think there was a scene that Neil druckman
cut out were Ellie's taking a [__] on the toilet
and she's admiring the girls in the magazines I
want to see that deleted scene like now I'm really
pining to see that like whoa now you're coming
across like a pervert no that's I was saying you
want to see that so I think I think belly probably
when I say belly that's bellaranda Bella and Ellie
Belly I think someone said that already I probably
go somewhere but yeah that's funny I I think she
could deliver like really go into the bathroom
because there were some non-sayers things she
couldn't play Ellie the right way but I think she
could deliver like going to the bathroom like with
convenience and doing it the right way so I I want
to see you around on a toilet in the magazine yeah
I want to see that this is what we contribute to
the Easter eggs yeah the entire scene takes place
in a piece Salon which completely juxtaposing
the idea of beauty against the devastation that
the world's now in we see Joel's hands trembling
which he diagnoses as a hairline fracture after
beating the crap out of the guy last week and
trembling are of course a sign of infection and
it's something that test later has so you can see
why she questions it here when she returns they in
a beating and Joel and Tess eat some crap bars I
think they're called crap bars while Stelly has a
delicious chicken sandwich this was given to her
by Marlene and it hints to how important she is
since they're willing to give a what would
be top of the range food in the Apocalypse
Now tying back to the whole bread thing it is
possible that Ellie was given this because she's
immunicordyceps and therefore there's no risk of
her getting infected good point good point damn
who knows what's in the crops though that might
be me going too far interestingly though there
was a real life case in France that happened
in the 50s that could have inspired this I've
done a full in-depth breakdown on this in our
video about how the infection started which is
up on the channel now now just for the cliff notes
though there was some ergot that ended up in bread
and this caused severe food poisoning and
hallucinations there was a man who thought
he was an airplane and he ended up jumping off a
two-story balcony whoa in episode one The Sign is
said that there could be LSD like hallucinations
given and this could tie back to that attempted
to strangle their own mother showing how it could
affect someone's rage all in all 250 people were
affected by it and 50 of these were condemned
to an asylum it's a really interesting story
and like I say I've done a longer video on it but
the important thing to take from it is no carbs
till mobs but I'm on Atkins Ellie says they're
trying to get her to an outpost out west and
there's going to be doctors there who can help
work on a cure Joel really doesn't believe this
at all and we'll talk in our spoiler section at
the end how this setup what's to come Tess just
wants to finish the job but she's starting to gain
faith in Ellie and we can see her coming around if
Ali is indeed able to help with a cure then that
would make her one of the most important people
that have ever lived but it just so happens that
she's been slotted up with some let's say Marley
gray characters out the way of the door and often
you drop these other ones when escaping in order
to stop people or the infected coming after you
speaking of the infected I was sure I heard the
sound effect of a clicker when they open up the
door so did I ever did it sound like that ah yeah
on the same page as you now speaking of the game
they actually skip over a big section with the
two skyscrapers it was a bit good that we didn't
get to this bit as it's such a major part of the
game early on they also finished last week's
episode by showing a shot of it to tease what
was to come and there's a clicker oh yeah that's
right there was that moment that I saw it on Tick
Tock yeah where there's a clip right there bottom
left there this is my first time actually seeing
it in the wide frame yeah oh that is crazy yeah
people in our comments have said that like did you
see the clicker I'm like what are you guys are the
buildings you guys are making [__] up there's no
clicker there but sure enough there was a quicker
and while I know the skyscraper scene was a big
part of of the game I really didn't even think
about it until like you just reminded me about
it right now were you consciously aware of it I
was I mean I played the game so many times it I
mean it was I would have been cool to see it it
didn't affect the the storyline or the episode
it was more of like I was just more saddened
just from a visual perspective but from a store
storyline perspective I didn't feel it hurt the
episode so I wasn't bothered in that sense in the
video game we get to meet our first clicker in the
the skyscraper building so I thought like that was
a cool touch whereas in the episode we get to see
the clicker in the museum for the first time they
changed it up a little bit but again it doesn't
like it didn't hurt the storyline well what they
expand on here sometimes they have to cut out some
other stuff exactly and we might get some other
skyscraper scene later on in the game there's a
lot of skyscraper related things you got to do now
as we see from the skyscrapers they'd probably be
impossible to climb and descent in real life due
to the angle at the rat in the game he climbed
at one and descended down the other during the
night and this was all done to escape the federal
Camp as you made your way through you came across
fresh bodies and also encountered the clickers
for the first time after seeing one grown into
a wall this is something that was teased out last
week and one leaps out at you as you open a door
and you have to navigate past them as you make
your way through this structure you just wanted
to have the one big clicker scene for the episode
and due to the budget I probably thought that the
museum later on would be the best place to do
without this too is a location that features in
the game as well with a civil war display being a
major part that we'll get into now in the game you
have to climb scaffolding and due to one of the
skyscrapers being at an angle they do some really
cool stuff with the physics eventually you make
your way through a train station and what's one of
the tensest parts of the game before you finally
Escape downtown which is where you sworn by the
infected this is an awesome scene and they almost
grab you from behind the shutter and I had to
hand it to them I love this moment now in the show
they go the longer scenic route for the first time
looking at the bombing and what the Government
tried to do in order to stop the spread they
hit most of the big cities like this they had to
slow the spread somehow so what happened here they
bombed the hell out of the surrounding areas to
the quarantine zones hoping to kill as much of the
infected as possible along the way she walks past
a stuffed giraffe toy and these actually appeared
throughout the game at several points they showed
up in Sarah's room on the ground and you don't
and we'll talk about it in that super spoiler
section section section exclusive spoons and
here they make their way alongside a highway
letter with cars and I absolutely love the look
here really recaptures the game turning this into
an urban jungle where Nature has taken over once
more definitely Ellie brings up how she got bit
and this happened in a mall inside the qz this
all took place in the Left Behind DLC and Ellie
says that she was just in there alone which again
super spoiler section at the end we'll also be
discussing some of the infected that she talks
about here and I'm guessing that this is all
setting up what's coming down the line anyway
after hearing the Cry of the infected they decide
to head into the hotel in the show this happens
much earlier than it does in the game where
they're not appearing until the Pittsburgh chapter
it really managed to recapture the look of it
though with a central stairwell and flooding being
present in the game you made your way behind the
reception desk and kikachu Bellboy trolley similar
to what we see in the show there's also a grand
piano channel that makes an appearance and it's
here that Joel talks about his love for coffee Ali
asks if they've ever stayed in a place like this
and Tess says do you ever stay in a place for my
blood ah no a little out of our league now this
is a no to the line in the game when they first
enter the hotel too rich for my blood oh fancy
you ever stayed a place like this
too rich for my two Rich for my blood I guess
I remembered it I guessed it good job Craig
thank you brought back PTSD flashbacks of all
those wooden pallets oh I wish they did that
never again um just so it's out there I can't
swim well I I don't know how to swim seriously
I love when they bag on each other and I think
they've included this bit as a nod to the game
and that it's highly unlikely you'll be returning
here again in the show this kind of sucks as it
also has another big bit with the infected but
you know with the show changing some bits and
adding in others we might get a payoff similar
to that and they end up ascending which is when
Tess climbs through a gap in order to unlock a
door for them in the game he grabbed a ladder
and navigated your way up the building which is
where you encountered some Bandits now where are
the things that we ran into which we'll save for
later in case they adapt it into a later part of
the show either way here they use the time for
some character development with Jill and Ellie
being forced into an awkward conversation Joel
is clearly a close book at this point and he
lies about where he's from and won't even answer
whether he and Tess are an item it's important
to bear in mind that at this point in the story
Jill's pretty much just a shell of his former self
and due to the death of Sarah he refuses to get
attached to anything he knows the pain that comes
from loss and his sole focus is on just making it
through the day-to-day because of his past also
knows that surviving means you have to do awful
things and thus he doesn't really like to make
alliances in case it comes to a point where it's
him or them standing in the way of tomorrow that's
me and all my friendships and this is a weapon
that she uses throughout the game now out on
the hotel balcony the group look out and they see
piles of infected yeah way more overpowered than
what they are in the game and we learn that they
have an almost high-like mind due to the fungus
connecting them in the game if you killed a group
of them that was it and you were completely safe
however here even if you kill one they have the
ability to reach out and call in the Cavalry the
fungi works like a connected brain and from the
vast strains that live underground they're almost
like telephone wires joining up the locations can
you imagine if that's how it was in the game it
was just been the scariest [__] in the world of
like this level's never gonna end not only that
you would run out of ammo American Weaponry very
quickly this was a really cool expansion I was
like oh wow never thought about like this how the
the fungus can just attach to the to the dead and
then call out to the other ones and Signal where
they are because I remember in the game they were
attracted to noise and then when a certain horde
or a certain amount uh were done okay now you just
move on but whenever like they got attacked by a
certain group of uh Runners clickers or whatever
it's because they were attracted to the noise
or they were already affecting that area well
I think using this fungi and hive mind way
of communicating is stronger visually for a
television series because it keeps that theme
alive of that tethered viral connection you
know it has a virus element feel more contagious
just with the fact that they do feel that much
more connected in a way that is non-human it adds
to the tension like okay they might be safe for
the moment but like another horde can come at any
moment so you never feel like they're they're safe
if one dies somewhere it can signal is and thus
the survivors are constantly on the Run trying
to get away in the show killing an infected person
doesn't mean you're out of danger and I love this
added Dimension to them now this massive pile
of infected could also tine with episode one we
of course open with a time Jump by following a
child trying to make their way to the qz they'd
been with a larger group and it's possible that
these newly infected people here are where the kid
broke off from and they also use the landscape
to very much show the objective and where you
need to head Moody dog had some incredible level
design and throughout the game you'd often see
where way needed to go demonstrated by being yes
in Boston they had the girl in down with the State
Building constantly off in the background which is
something that the show also does too great I've
never been a Boston myself but but I've seen the
golden dome in the department and obviously it's
a sign of status in that movie so get this so
yeah the bit of info there haven't haven't been
in Boston but I've seen it just talking about
this movie today some TripAdvisor now realizing
they have no other way around they go to the
museum which is ripped right out of the game in
there there was a wooden beam that fell blocking a
doorway similar to what happens later on when they
get trapped the game had this separating gel from
tessinelli and you had to navigate past clickers
in the infected back up to them in it you run into
a civil war display which is something that also
appears in the series as well it was lined with
cases that Hobbit all muskets and rifles which
are another thing that they perfectly bring across
to the series who's also an officer's uniform and
this appears in the lobby as they step inside the
building initially seems safe because the roots
outside of rotten away but the open door signal
knows that something else is going on they catch a
staff member grown into the ground there's also a
recently killed soldier that has been ripped apart
Tess is optimistic that they were attacked outside
and crawled in here to die but all it does is
signal that something else is in the building now
for me clickers were something that was gonna make
or break this series normally in zombie stuff you
tend to get your typical grunt zombies and it's
rare that it goes beyond that outside of Resident
Evil and left the Dead one of the big downsides
of The Walking Dead is that they just kept the
zombies and didn't really Elevate things from
there so you had this repetitive enemy throughout
the click as though they add this new dimension
and playing those encounters for the first time
in a dark room with headphones on was absolutely
terrifying yup if your so much has made a sound
then they would spring out the darkness and grab
you the worst thing is is that they were one hit
kills if you've seen the trailer the third trailer
the one that we did a reaction to in case you
haven't played the game on that creature that they
tease at the end that [__] was is that scary
but I play the game I'm just like running like
a madman and I'm so scared the entire time but
they tease that they're good it's gonna be in the
show and that I cannot wait to see I'm so excited
they're gonna need a lot of fire for that creature
but yeah now I'm excited yeah on high difficulties
even opening your backpack around them couldn't
let the clickers to your location and every
encounter was as intense as it can never opened
the Packers the show has managed to recapture
the tense atmosphere of them and I even found
myself sitting in complete silence because of how
nail biting it was as they get through the door
the beams collapse and even the shape of how it
falls looks like how it is in the game we see the
mannequins and display cases and these add extra
human shapes to the surroundings really elevating
the paranoia and fear in this scene one appears
behind a glass case and I kind of got flashes of
the T-Rex scene in Jurassic Park when they're in
the Jeep oh yeah yeah good yeah that's true let's
do a big fight with two whilst Ali crawls the
way out and Jill uses sound to distract them in
the game you throw bottles and Bricks but he tips
over a statue in order to draw one away he's also
able to keep his flashlight on and in the game
absolutely none of the infected reacted to lights
because the fungi just didn't pick up on it Joel
manages to reunite with Ali but the clicker senses
them after they step on broken glass you had to
be really careful when navigating around them as
there would often be piles on the floor that could
alert them at any second anyway they managed to
take them down but we later learned that test got
bit during this we're not sure exactly when this
happens but in the game you find her pushed up
against and have to save her which is when I've
always thought that it happens there agreed now
as they step outside and she sits down we can also
catch a blood stain on her coat wow my guess is
that the clicker pulled back and then dribble the
blood from his bite onto her right right I gotta
say the fact that Tess was boss enough to get a
clicker off of her you know like an infected it's
one thing you mean a runner or a stalker but then
when you get to a clicker Yeah the more the more
advanced they are dude we will have comment from
this off the technicalities I appreciate it you're
welcome but yeah no agreed with you because the
higher in the evolutionary uh gene pool you go the
stronger they are as you as the creature we didn't
mention earlier obviously we know that's the
strongest but yeah yeah but clickers are extremely
powerful and strong and you know if you don't have
a shiv in the game you're done yeah you can't push
that thing off she gets infected in the game by
a runner but here the show's implying that she
was able to get a clicker off of her she's been
working she's been working out that's something
that you shouldn't disregard that I think we need
to thank Robert for that for having those guys
beat her up so much you just got those workouts
and she's like yeah handle a clicker that's
nothing but that was also really interesting that
he mentioned the T-Rex I think if they wanted to
hit us over the head they would have had like
you know some water with a cup and then just
have it vibrating and then change the clicker
noise tool sounded just like yeah you're like
perfect you're like Gabriel Luna and Tommy the
you are the T-Rex like spot on Ali walks past
a plank and this scene is pulled directly from
the game after escaping the museum they have to
cross one are we getting almost identical shot
of that when she makes her way across the beam
Tess clearly now she's on board time too and
she wants them to see the positive news in her
surviving the bite I like that they added that
we get this line pulled directly from the game
you hope for so is that everything you hope
for jury's still out jury's still out oh man
she had to know that view
can't deny that view hey let's pick it up
I'm feeling something I'd like that
they added them looking at his watch
the game yeah a jail also looks longingly at his
watch this brief glance that it carries a lot of
meaning as it of course reminds him of Sarah Ali
sort of becomes the surrogate daughter to him and
it's almost like he has a moment remembering
his own life before it all went to hell this
is a really important scene as the watch of course
broke when Sarah died this was very much when the
World Ended as well and time stopped for Joel
in the exact same second that his watch broke
anyway they make their way into the building
with Joel Still suspecting Ellie might not
be the real deal shares a bandage to cover her
bite and in the game when you'd pat yourself up
with a Medicare you could also see bandages like
this over the wounds after arriving at the State
Building they see a truck full of dead Firefly
soldiers and also I think it's worth pointing
out that Joel has an assault right he didn't get
that till the hospital as in the game I always
saw him as being more of a pistol in shotgun man
for moving on now on the way to the location I
came across a soldier with a firefly logo on his
arm and he had a note detailing that they were
gonna look after the girl inside they discover
the Dead and we learned that one got bit which
led to everyone turning on each other Tess is in
this situation too and after revealing her bite
they let her handle things on her own terms Joel
is actually a little bit apprehensive over this
and you can see she comes towards him that he
starts to step back the scenes play out really
similarly to the game with his getting a few
lines of dialogue that marry each other here
foreign
one of them's got to have a map on them right
where was this lab of theirs where did Marlene
say that she was taking out west Ellie she never
said she only mentioned that it was someplace
out west uh I don't know just west listen
I'm probably gonna get some crap for this
the one thing I definitively know so far
I preferred the test portrayal in the show
over the game like especially the actress's
voice seems like yeah you're the kind of woman
I just not that the cat girl in in the game I
want to mess with that version of tests either
but this version doesn't like yeah you're like
super intimidating right off the bat there's
more of this like wait in history and the way
her voice Community just just a voice alone I
actually preferred the interpretation that I
don't know the actress's name Anna Torv nice
bring the a game here yeah even just watching it
back to back I'm like yeah I definitely prefer
the actress I mean she's fantastic I don't know
if I'm ready to say that yeah she's phenomenal I
definitely like the relationship between her and
Joel in the show a little bit better so far yeah
no I mean it's a fair point what you're saying
I don't think you deserve crap for that I mean
everyone's allowed to have a version that they
they like but we're talking with fandoms all we
do is talk crap on each other yeah everyone
everyone's we don't respect other people's
opinions and what world do you live in you make
a fair point but again I like the relationship I
like the history the sense of history and I like
the Romantic history that we feel between Joel
and Tesson and the TV show a lot better I like the
chemistry with these two a lot as well fair enough
you're wrong our luck had to run
out sooner or later run out sooner
she's infected
I Was Bitten an hour ago and it's
already worse this is [__] real Joel
he's real she just looks so Disturbed isn't she
her facial expressions are phenomenal revealing
her bite we hear fedra soldiers storming the
area test buys them some time to escape and
he stays behind to shoot it out with them which
is when he's eventually killed here the infected
are alerted with them scrambling from the areas
tips over some explosive barrels and also some
grenade so that she can take them all out it's
such a tense scene watching them close in as she
struggles to spark a pillow so much attention and
her hands trembling because of the infection Ted
has then given the kiss of death and she drops
the ladder taking them all out now in the game
at this point you descended into the subway
station which is where the fedra followed you
until you run into some Infected they decided
to cut their losses and leave and it led to you
going further into the underground here though
I actually like the impact and the time that
they give to Tess's death he didn't really get a
moment to breathe originally but I just love the
devastation that kind of washes over this scene
Joel as always continues moving but at least
a still hit with a realization of just how quickly
things can change in this world yep see that's one
thing that the show is really taking advantage
of is being willing to shift perspectives because
like in the game whenever you're playing as
the character you're only in their perspective
so works in the game when tests his whole death
scene actually happens off screen because you're
still just playing as Joel and early locked so
you really feel like you're in that perspective
and locked in as the player whereas in a show it
allows you the opportunity to shift perspectives
and just focus on this is only Tess is seen at
this moment you know absolutely and just really
quickly I love to that they changed instead of the
fedra coming in and then doing it off screen they
had you know stalkers and Runners and all that
coming in and then we get a heroic Sacrifice from
Tess and this was such a badass sacrifice one of
the most badass sacrifices ever you had time to
breathe on the moment like just to feel it it's
a lot more gut I mean it's still sad in the game
for sure but this is a lot more gut wrenching
because again you're just so invested in tests
at this point it really is one of life and death
and it speaks about that characters in the game
Ali would even press Joel to talk about Tess and
he'd refuse to because we don't talk about tests
to what happened it's a devastating way to end
the episode with them now on the other side of
the building and that golden dome hanging over
them in the background now that takes us into
the Super spoiler super duper trademark greatest
of all time spoiler section exclusive exclusive
if you haven't played both games then duck out
now and also please hit the thumbs up button on
your way out I love you so we're allowed to talk
spoilers Now link to larger parts of the game
initially when they talk about how the fireflies
are working on a cure Joel says he's heard this a
thousand times before and he's extremely skeptical
over it now this could be the show setting up why
he does what he does down the line and Joel
eventually gets Ellie to the fireflies but he
learns that in order to make a cure that Ali has
to die thus he turns in a Rambo and kills all the
fireflies and surgeons before they can operate on
her this line here adds way to him not believing
that it's worth sacrificing her for sewing that
might not even work and I appreciate that they
added then in the scene Joel also refuses to let
her have a gun when she asks this was mirrored in
the game as well and it was only after the hotel
where she saved his life that he started to begin
trusting her now the draft toy was also a nice
little Touch Too the end of the first game has a
major scene in it in which Joel and Ellie come
across them and it shows that though humanity
is doomed there is hope for the rest of the world
Adrian Wildlife has flourished and it's one of the
most memorable moments in that first game I'm in
the PlayStation classic when they're in the hotel
they get a letter and climb up which is when they
run into Bandits before making it to An Elevator
Shaft here everything goes to hell and Ellie and
Jola could off from each other which is when you
descend into the basement into what's one of the
most scariest parts of the game I'm hoping yeah
it really was the stalkers and in it Joe basically
navigates through the basement in what one of the
most tensest scenes of all time in these dark
and Dan Carlos you run into infected and also
blotter which Ellie touched upon earlier in the
episode she asked if rumors about the ones that
threw two toxic gas are people were true and this
is a reference to the giant infected that you run
into in the game the longer someone is infected
the longer they mutate and in the last of us too
you come across the Rat King oh that's the worst
the wrecking from where it all went down and on
the day kicked off they destroyed the stairwells
and ended up locking them everyone's favorite
characters roughly 25 years it was completely
incredible how messed up he got oh they also
have some neat little nods to The Last of Us
Part Two where the Flies went beyond appearing
in episode 1 and we could also see one of Joel's
guitar and Ellie even got one as a tattoo yep huge
United ebony Maldonado for pawning at the shirt
lus in the second game is also the one that Joe
ah no way why didn't I notice that wow this was
the next location where Joel and Ali went to we
discovered that Frank had left and he's made
his way to part of the town that bill refused
to venture to however he did in order to help Joel
and Ellie and they went into his school to get a
military truck battery this was in there but they
kept pushing through and eventually found Frank's
Body which is when they learned that he'd taken
it Frank had been bitten so he'd taken his own
life it was pretty heartbreaking for Belle even
if he didn't show it a judging by the trailers it
looks like they're changing things for next time
I will of course be back for that so make sure you
stay locked in answer my thoughts on the episode
I think it was handled really well and these two
entries have been the best video game adaptations
that I've ever seen an aesthetic of the game and
every character is really knocking it out of the
park in terms of their delivery in action sir plus
the clickers were great too and I love this track
through the landscape of an overgrown Boston that
was full of danger now I kind of wish they'd
done the skyscrab a bit in live action but I
can understand why that probably wasn't achievable
without completely blowing the budget it's also
the hotel as well which I hope wasn't the only
time that will appear in the series because
obvious locations had major moments with the
infected that I think would translate so well
to the show I think we'll use those sequences
in other ways Blown Away by it and I hope we
get those bits here fingers crossed we do now
obviously I would love to hear your thoughts on
the show so make sure you comment below and let me
know I think you have to like use some more like
they would cut out some of these tent sequences
for the show because you have to use them a little
more sparingly in uh a show or it also could feel
feel more repetitive in the show that doesn't
even sometimes the complaint with last of us too
for some some players even though I I personally
gameplay wise I agree but story wise first
one for me but specifically on the gameplay
it gets a little repetitive after a while on
a show it can feel that way so I think a lot
of these sequences that we love will just get
like variations of that sort of more spread
out throughout the show hopefully that's just my
hope but anyway there's another great breakdown
Paul you did it you nailed it you nailed it Paul
constantly nailing it becoming super successful
unbelievably Filthy Rich alrighty guys Andrew
thanks for being here thanks for having me heavy
spoilers go subscribe show his video some love
as he's got more videos of Last of Us coming
out that are more than just the breakdowns
all right guys talk with you all soon keep
the lookout for episode three reaction coming up
in a six days I did math right yeah see you guys